les kidd who is a professor at berkeley
and she works on
language acquisition knowledge
acquisition in young children
using um an uh combination of
computational behavioral methods
and uh she says she draws um
inspiration both from classical
psychology so she's in the department of
psychology
and also with new computational methods
with very current techniques
and she's a wonderful speaker and i've
once i've met her on a panel before in
berkeley
she's been at rutgers she got a phd from
rutgers i think
postdoc at mit and um i think there's a
lot to learn from human learning
when we try to apply it to even
non-humans because some people think of
babies as
not quite human yet uh so celeste please
take it away and thank you very much for
willing to give us this talk and thank
you so much shafiah i really appreciate
it and
uh thank you very much to all organizers
for uh inviting me
inviting me here to talk um uh
so today i'm going to be talking about
how humans gain the foundational
knowledge that allows them to
communicate
um i i called my talk the foundations of
early human
learning but obviously i was like it's
also the foundations of later human
learning
so even though a lot of the work is with
babies it's not really about babies it's
how people learn to communicate and more
broadly than that how they form beliefs
and learn things in general
language con language acquisition is a
huge topic so i'm necessarily going to
have to pick and choose just a subset
of different aspects to focus on
specifically i'm going to be focusing on
a few
core general principles that human
infants employ
in the process of learning to
communicate with others
language learning i thought jonathan's
talk did a great job of setting up
involves building a lot of higher order
representations from
lower level ones uh startings with
things like
uh uh you know the place of articulation
aspects of the sounds
uh then moving up to syllables uh then
from syllables moving up to
words and from words to what the words
refer to in the world
the reference uh to concepts and
categories and and so on and so on
language is one of the few human
conceptual domains in which we have a
handle on the psychological components
of
uh the conceptual representations in a
way that allows us to know something
about the the way that they're related
to each other
that kind of hierarchy uh what so
that that that feature of it makes it a
potentially useful domain
for studying the nature of concepts and
learning in general
what i want to do in this talk is walk
through some key principles that human
use
starting in infancy but continuing
through adulthood to not just
learn language but to learn everything
else
i'm going to limit myself to just four
ways in which we as humans learn to
communicate
and learn and learn about things in the
world
so the first thing uh that baby humans
need to do in order to get a handle on
communication
is to track statistics uh specifically
they're tracking statistics from their
environment
um babies enter the world able to
attract co-occurrences
and use them to make sense of the world
actually not just not just
uh at birth are they able to do that i
was like they track statistics about
things like the rhythmic properties of
their language uh
in in utero and uh are born with some
uh rudimentary knowledge of some aspects
of their linguistic environment
one of the major pieces of evidence that
we have for
infant's ability to do statistical
learning is his work by jenny safran
with dick aslan and lisa newport
this work examined how infants hear a
continuous speech stream and somehow
figure out where the individual words
are
unlike words on the written page spoken
words don't have any breaks between them
if you ever heard a language that you
don't speak uh you know it's it's it's
difficult to be able to pull out just
one word from it
uh so that's the position that infants
are in when they're when they're
learning their target language
uh if you consider a phrase that a baby
might hear something like
pretty baby from the infant's point of
view
that could all be one word uh or it
could be four
pretty a and b uh or two or three
uh with just that string by itself
there's no way to know
except for uh the the two-word edges
um you know you know that those are
boundaries um but
uh where the other boundaries are how
many words this is
is unclear uh so uh the idea that jenny
saffron and her colleagues had was that
maybe
infants could track statistics across
syllables
across utterances uh as they're
listening to speech incoming
uh and use those statistics in order to
work out where the words were
so if you look at these phrases phrases
you start to notice that certain chunks
track together
so a baby could hear a phrase like
pretty mama
and pretty kitty and notice that pretty
tends to move together as a unit so
maybe prettiest won't work
uh they could hear happy baby and silly
baby
uh and notice again that baby is moving
together as a unit
and in that way by tracking those uh
transitional statistics
uh figure out where the word boundaries
are
there's a catch so for them to be able
to do that uh
you'd have to demonstrate that infants
are capable of tracking the transitional
statistics
between a relatively large number of
different types of units
over many different many different
syllables so
they designed an experiment to test to
see if infants could could do that
and in this experiment they played two
minutes of this speech stream for
infants composed of nonsense syllables
like this
let me play a little segment so you can
kind of hear it
and you you you you get the get the gist
so that's just a little clip
um and uh whoops uh this this nonsense
language
uh that they played to infants was
constructed uh in a way that it was
composed of
novel word-like units that moved
together uh so the transaction
transitional statistics between the
syllables uh are
are different if you were tracking the
transitional statistics
you could theoretically identify two
different types of items that could be
pulled from this stream
novel words composed of syllables that
are tracking together
and what they called part words which
occurred in the speech stream but
contained
incontained syllables that all occurred
equally often in the speech stream
but that did not occur as often as a
unit together
after just two minutes of exposure to
this nonsense language
infants showed that they were able to
differentiate between
these two different types of items from
from the speech stream
the ones that traveled together as units
and the ones that did not specifically
they showed a greater interest in the
part words a pattern commonly
interpreted as indicating
that infants found those part words
surprising
this was some of the first big evidence
that infants can track statistics and
use them
to form new concepts and uh it started a
a a wave of other
experiments showing that it wasn't just
in the domain of speech
that just tracking environmental
statistics as they come in
could be useful so
uh this was not just limited to
uh the auditory domain this is this is
uh some visual stimuli from an
experiment by joseph pfizer and dick
aslan
showing that uh infants can also track
uh visual co-occurrence statistics uh
this is
uh uh some some some visual scenes that
are composed of a kind of grammar
uh they're these little um units that
are like words
um that uh infants are presented with
and just as they did with the auditory
stimuli they're able to notice
uh when two uh two shapes
uh are in the same configuration across
multiple different displays
uh so they're able to infer the lexicon
from from a surprisingly small amount of
exposure
statistical learning is a powerful
domain general mechanism
that could potentially explain a lot of
great learning feats including learning
language
uh it's simple it's powerful uh and uh
the concept says
it allows you to learn can can build
over time uh
in reflecting in the in the sense of
building up a hierarchy
um to to acquiring a full full bone
full-blown language
um uh and we know that that ability is
shared by many other species incu
including non-human primates uh rats
songbirds and many others
uh there's a great uh 2018 review by
uh kiara salus santolin and jenny safran
uh that i'd recommend checking out it
came out in
in transit cognitive sciences in in 2018
we know that human infants use this
general learning mechanism to build up
their knowledge over time
building bigger representations out of
the last set of building blocks that
they acquired
so initially uh human infants track
statistics over syllables in order to
learn that there's a spoken word apple
uh then they track the co-occurrence
statistics between that word
and objects in the world uh in order to
learn what apple
is actually referring to uh to
eventually uh using statistics in order
to form
a a category of apples that includes
red apples and green apples uh but
excludes
uh oranges and and peaches and so on and
so on
uh increasingly building higher levels
of representation
so the goal of the infant is to
eventually acquire
an adult-like understanding about how
things work in the world
including different concepts and how
those concepts can be combined
this mechanism i mentioned is not just
powerful for learning about language
it's also what humans are using
in order to learn about what causes what
in the world it allows you to learn how
things work
so this is how you build up your adult
model of the the
mental model of the world uh the better
and the more accurate your predictions
uh with with your mental model uh the
better decisions that you can
you can make um and the more the more
you can optimize utility
um but this is where it gets really
interesting uh this mental model of the
world that's generating the expectations
uh it's also helping you generate
expectations about
where in the world you should search for
the next set of information
uh so the early things that you learn
are feeding into your subsequent
decisions
it's directly shaping where you attend
to where you look and ultimately what
you know of the world
the difficulty in in finding truth for
us as humans is that there's far more
knowledge in the world
than any one person could possibly ever
obtain
which means that an individual is forced
to pick and choose
each moment when a person has selected
one thing to learn from
they're necessarily missing out on
everything else
so each choice matters because it's
coming with a huge opportunity cost
as a very simple example uh you only
have one set of eyes so
uh if you are sitting and you are
looking in one direction you're
necessarily missing out on anything
that's happening
all the directions that you're not
fixating i was like behind you for
example
uh that simple fact has has really
profound implications
uh it means that to be a person in the
world you you have to pick and choose
uh you're going to be having to form
beliefs based on just a
small subset of all of the information
that's theoretically available to you in
the world
and you're not conscious of it but
you're making at least half a million
decisions
a very quick decisions every day about
where to look
uh what to explore what to click what to
read what to listen to
who to talk to etc etc how you make
those decisions is informed by what you
already know
what you believe to be true and where
you expect to have uncertainty
you have to make those decisions very
quickly so there's there's no time to
lament them
and you're limited to sampling and
forming beliefs of course
based on what's available to you as an
individual
so the second thing uh human infants do
to learn uh
is that they seek out uh what isn't
understood
our systems have a very effective
built-in mechanism
for helping us avoid wasting time and
navigating the challenges of
information overload in the world and
that mechanism's common name
is is boredom for example our systems
engage boredom
when we're confident that we know
everything that there is to know uh this
is very rational i was like why should
you keep
uh watching if you already if you
already know everything there's no
learning value
these systems uh are good in that they
prevent us from hyper fixating
uh but they do so at the cost of
sometimes shutting down the information
tap
uh before we've gotten the right idea uh
so they are they are not perfect systems
uh i'm not gonna be focusing on that in
today's talk but
last week i gave a tech talk at x that
does focus on that so if you're
interested
uh you can you can search for that or
message me
in my lab we've used eye trackers to
study the principles that guide our
sampling and learning
i'm going to tell you about a set of
studies we did with human infants
uh in this section uh these these
studies taught us a lot about human
infants solve
that that sampling problem that i made
reference to
how we as humans weigh information gain
against opportunity cost
so in this series of experiments we
showed infants displays that were
designed to elicit expectations
while allowing us to construct a
reasonable probabilistic model
of these expectations moment to moment
as the displays unfolded over time
the in these displays objects popped out
of boxes in some order
i'll show you what that looks like these
experiments with infants always start
with an attention getter and we use a
baby who is laughing because babies
really like looking at other babies
do you guys hear it okay okay
so there's objects popping out of boxes
there's exactly one object
in each box um across the trials there's
different boxes with different objects
uh
yes hopefully you get the intuition that
some are
more surprising there's the attention
getter again and i'll show you just a
couple
a couple moves to that one that one
keeps keeps going
um uh this is cuter this is a baby
sitting and doing the experiment uh so
as long as she kept looking the design
is contingent
uh as long as she keeps looking uh the
displays keep
unfolding uh objects keep popping out of
boxes
um the mom is wearing headphones so that
the parent can't influence
what that what the kid is interested in
she almost looks away but doesn't
[Music]
and she looks away for criterion time of
one second
laughing baby comes back she resets
and we can just do that over and over
again uh
so we can get a large amount of data um
from from each baby
okay um to quantify these expectations
we applied a textbook example from
bayesian statistics
a dirichlet multinomial which provides
an estimate of probability
uh that each box will activate next
given the previous sequence of events
uh at each point in time uh the baby
either looks away or they don't and
if they don't then we move on to the
next the next trial
uh the next sorry the next box pops up
we can take the posterior of each action
at each moment in time and then use it
to compute a surprisal value for each
event in the sequence
uh with this in hand we can then plot
the probability of
infant's actual look away behavior as a
function of the surprisal value
of the vet this allows us to uncover the
relationship between
idealized probabilistic expectations
and children's behavior in a simple and
independent way
and when we do that we get what we've
described as
a goldilocks effect by which uh i mean
that infants
tend to look away at events that are
highly predictable but also they tend to
look away at events that are highly
surprising
like this it also applies controlling
for other factors like the posterior
entropy
and even holds when we model
transitional probabilities
which are important in language learning
rather than doing each each event
independently
uh it's true not just of visual
attention
attention to visual sequences but also
auditory ones as well
that's really important to know since uh
auditory statistics are likely to be
most important for the first stages of
language learning
uh oh and i should also mention i was
like we have new data
there's a paper under review uh it's
also true for older children
uh children over three years old uh we
just did some new work that was led by
uh now you pen post doctoral scholar uh
laura suskey
uh who's who's working at the the center
for autism research
uh here's an example of an infant doing
an auditory version of the task
one in which the model is estimating the
surprisal based on the occurrence of
items in the sound sequence
not things in the visual sequence uh so
we're still using the eye tracker
uh and uh using that to
allow the infant to control what they
see uh we're using a visual display in
order to keep their attention
uh but we're holding it constant in
changing the items in the auditory
[Music]
sequence
so same guy over and over again and the
sounds are what's wearing
she looks away she gets another trial
um we get that same goldilocks effective
disengagement
at points of high and low surprisal here
as well
uh so uh this this guiding principle
um doesn't just apply at the group
average level it also applies at the
level of individual inference
uh this kind of u-shaped function we
think represents
a broadly applicable strategy for
organizing your search for information
in the world
learning scientists had previously
suggested that this kind of a pattern
might be helpful for allowing users to
seek out things
that are valuable for learning uh for
example
uh if you imagine picking a book to read
you can imagine that this abc book is
not
very attractive as an option because
as an adult who knows my abcs i already
know this
there's not a lot of new information
that i can gain there
but on the opposite end of the spectrum
if you're to go for the most new
information possible
say you pick a book on a topic you don't
know anything about i don't know
anything about billiards
in a language that you do not yet speak
you could potentially learn
two things at once but you really can't
because you can't get any traction i was
like you're missing the base levels of
representation
that you need in order to make sense of
it
instead the most attractive option falls
in the goldilocks zone
so something like a book in a language i
i speak on a topic on which i have some
background
this is a new one that i'm reading right
now which is very good
these kinds of decisions we think
originate with the same
type of cognitive system which favors
material that is a little bit surprising
but not overly surprising given what you
currently understand
importantly in order to exhibit such
regularities
uh linking attention in an idealized
model of the stimuli
infants have to be tracking those
statistics and building expectations
about the world
and using those in order to to to guide
uh
their decisions about whether to
continue watching or to disengage
this idea is consistent with a lot of
other evidence that we have from
developmental psych
that suggests that uh very young uh
humans seek out experiences that violate
their expectations but just a little
uh so for example in displays like this
uh if a ball is animated to bounce
around in a box with a hole
in one side just one hole in one side
and three holes in the other
infants attend longer when the ball
exits out of the less likely side
which you might expect is an indicator
that means that they find that
surprising
uh and they attend for less long when
the ball does the
more likely thing so the ball flies out
of the side that has more holes in it
uh possibly the more expected side uh
then they're they're not as interested
if it doesn't violate your expectations
it carries little information so you're
less interested
um there's cool work from people like
laura schultz and liz bonowitz with
older kids
suggesting that uh young humans uh
don't don't just follow this a pattern
in terms of
deciding where to attend to uh they also
follow it when they're deciding what to
play with uh
so uh they have this study
uh where there's these toys that look
like this um and kids will play longer
with the toy
uh when they haven't yet observed
evidence uh that makes clear what the
causal structure of the toy is
uh so this these these boxes um uh
have two levers and two puppets that pop
out of the top
uh the manipulation is is the uh
demonstration that they get before
they're offered the opportunity to play
with it
uh either both levers are pulled at once
so it is unclear
uh which lever leads to which puppet
popping out
or they're demonstrated one at a time
and if you demonstrate the confounded
evidence
uh that toy is a lot more attractive
indicating that
uh kids are seeking opportunities to
learn about the causal structure of the
world
okay three three out of four things this
is the third thing
once you're tracking the statistics and
using them to guide your search
you can also leverage statistically
reliable cues
to gather additional information about
communication
and everything else worth learning i'm
going to pick just two examples from our
lab
for example we've looked at toddler's
ability to leverage a somewhat
unexpected cue
in order to learn language more
effectively that unexpected cue
is speech disfluencies including uh
and um while you probably don't
intentionally produce these uh they are
a feature of natural speech
uh and if you think that you don't
produce them uh i
i promise you for not not memorize
things you do uh and
if you'd like i can point them out but
you'll be self-conscious for days so
um i i warn you um so
uh the thing about speech influences is
that they occur in predictable places
um specifically uh before words that are
infrequent
uh and also before object labels that
are new
to the conversation
so pretend that these two objects are
present on a counter and i said i was
going to make some orange juice
now imagine if i asked if you could
please hand me the
you probably feel your eyes drifting
over to the juicer
um and not to the orange and if this
were a real life situation
uh it's it's very likely you'd start to
reach over to the juicer
um without me even having gotten to the
word juicer
so uh you can anticipate i'm going to
say juicer because
oranges are previously mentioned if i
was talking about orange juice and
oranges are also a more frequent word
than juicer so because they
were just mentioned and they're more
frequent they're less likely to
uh induce processing difficulties that
result in the speech disfluency um
small humans are are also capable of uh
drawing that inference about a speaker's
referential intentions
uh in an experiment that we ran a while
back we presented toddlers who spoke
just
just a few words themselves so these are
not super verbal kids
with similar situations each one
featuring
a frequent um mentioned object
and then one unmentioned novel one we
used eye trackers
uh like before to measure where on the
screen that they looked
and specifically we were interested in
the period
right before the object was named uh
that spot was either
occupied by a a bit of fluent speech
or by lengthening like the
and a filled paws disfluency like uh
we wanted to know if the disfluency
prompted the infants to look towards the
weirder unmentioned object
and what we found that this is a skill
that develops over time
uh and starts to emerge around two years
of age
uh and continues um to develop uh
through the early portion of a kid's
life this is something that
um uh adults uh are able to do as if
adults are able to to use this cue in
order to anticipate what somebody is
going to talk
talk talk about next uh and even young
kids although they're not saying very
many words themselves they've picked up
on the statistical regularity
um for two-year-olds this is a very
useful trick because
kids are still in the process of
learning uh what
words in the world mean i was like
they're in a period of
heavy uh vocabulary development
so allowing a kid to anticipate
that something that is infrequently
labeled is about to be mentioned
so that they can be ready and looking at
it
by the time the object label is actually
mentioned
is is hugely helpful this is just one in
a whole line of evidence demonstrating
how young kids are able to leverage
partial knowledge in order to gain more
i want to show you just one more example
from a study led by emily sumner and
erica deangelis
that we did a few years ago this study
uh how we did it is we asked kids to
choose
among two options in several different
games that we made up
i'm going to show you a video and what i
want you to do
is see if you can spot the regularities
in how this two-year-old is responding
does the playground have pine or oak
trees
oak trees look
it's a tree an oak tree where are you
gonna put it
next to the tv
yeah it's a school fence brick
or wood
oh very nice is rory shirt yellow
or red what red
right um so she's uh she's choosing the
choosing the second thing
um uh and this was a very common pattern
for kids
uh at this age to exhibit um uh
overwhelmingly kids in the early stages
of language production when they're
first starting to say
um uh say words and respond to questions
like these
uh they are very likely to choose the
second of two choices
that are offered upwards of 75 percent
of the time in the task i just i just
presented
um this effect uh you can see was was
large
uh and it didn't just occur in our weird
lab tasks
uh it also occurred in naturalistic
responses to parental questions that we
pulled from a giant corpus of kids
speech recordings called cultilus
this bias is very strong too and it
decreases in a naturalistic environment
as children learn more words and as they
mature
but you can bring it back in older
children
uh if you present them with choices that
are longer and
involve more syllables so if you're
trying to uh coerce your child into
making a particular choice while still
wanting them to feel like they are
making a choice themselves
uh this is a great strategy to use um uh
as you increase the number of syllables
presumably it increases the demands on
their working memory
uh and it we don't know exactly why it
might be the case but a
good possible explanation is um uh the
second thing is just is just more
accessible
um this uh is a good demonstration of
what you see in young kids is sometimes
not what you think it is
in language development research speech
productions word productions
are often taken as a gold standard as
evidence that the kid knows something
about
uh the concept to which that word refers
like this is a great demonstration
of uh kids saying things uh that they
probably don't know
they may not know on what what the
referent actually is
okay fourth and final thing uh you need
to do to learn to communicate
uh you continuously update everything
that you have learned human beliefs are
inferences not records
uh their probabilistic expectations a
lot of the time the way that we talk
about
kids languages is though once they've
learned something
they filed it away and they're done uh
it's baked into how we talk about these
things so you say things like
uh my toddler learn the word spoon
and you might think that if a child is
always using a word
in the correct context and
always recognizing it when it's spoken
to them uh that that concept is is at
least mostly
uh mostly mostly built but
um uh that's that's not at all how it
works and uh we don't have
a whole lot of empirical work with kids
probing exactly what their
concepts look like but it is very likely
uh
that they are far far away away from
from
adults concepts um uh
okay um so uh with every new piece of
data
that a kid experiences they're updating
their concept a little bit
uh and we also have evidence that that's
not just true of kids who are in the
early stages of building their
vocabulary
that's that's true of adults too so with
something like a spoon with every spoon
that you encounter
you update your concept just a teeny bit
and if you
move to a place that has spoons that are
more atypical
or in the future if culinary design
trends shift
uh towards shorter fatter spoons or
something like that uh your concept
shifts right along with those changes
and you don't even notice that that's
happening
your beliefs about spoons change right
along with the shifts and the data that
you're observing
since every child and every person takes
a different path through life
and encounters their own unique set of
sequence of spoons in this case uh it
makes sense
it follows that uh every person is going
to have
their own unique set of concepts
uh and more generally their own unique
set of beliefs about what's true in the
world
that maybe often roughly match
but which are uh unlikely to
be identical so we're interested
we were interested in measuring the
degree to which people in the population
share common concepts uh we were
interested in how much diversity there
is
uh and uh given that we expected to see
some diversity
uh are people aware of it when they're
communicating
to do this we asked people to rate
similarities between common concepts
following classic methods in cognitive
psychology from people like roger
shepard
and others some of these concepts were
political and some were just common
nouns we were interested in discovering
how many latent versions of each concept
lived in the population
this is a t sne plot colored according
to the clustering results from a chinese
restaurant process
where response vectors for each concept
were clustered across
individuals in the population for
instance
uh based on the responses people gave to
similarity judgments to richard nixon
we arrived at a distribution over
different nicks and concepts that people
might have in the population in this
experiment people were actually asked
twice
so this is their relative reliability in
answering
sorry what did they what did you ask
here i i missed it
oh that's okay i'll go back to the so so
they're asked a series of questions
most similar okay okay yeah so so it's a
it's a
binary choice and as like you get asked
to compare everyone to every other one
uh the reason why we use this approach
instead of just saying like
i don't know something more uh free form
um
we want to um be controlling for the
context so we're asking you to rate it
in this particular context and everybody
has the same context
um if you thought that we all had
basically the same concepts for these
words
uh what you'd expect to see is one
single cluster
but what we find instead is that there
are about five to ten
different distinct concept clusters for
each of these labels
in the population uh that said there's
not no difference between all of these
things
uh we use the species oh sorry i forgot
a detail
um we use a species count estimator from
ecology to extend the number of clusters
in our sample
to that of the entire population on the
planet
using methods like good turing
estimators we find that the number is
approximately what we should expect to
see for the entire population
in in our sample when we started this
work
we expected to see less variation for
concrete things that you could observe
and more variation for the abstract ones
and that turns out to mostly be true
but what we were surprised to see
is how much variation there is even
among uh the concrete the concrete
concepts
uh although people do uh vary more on
some concepts than others
um so here is salmon just pulling out uh
that has about three main types of
concepts
there's more agreement here and fewer
fewer fewer um
uh fewer types of concepts for salmon uh
but there's less agreement on this one
joe biden
the increased number of clusters here
indicates that joe biden
means means fundamentally different
things to different people
for this in our experiments and this uh
other experiments in this area we get
our similarity data in a way that's
controlling for the context
as i just mentioned so even in this this
same context
uh people's uh concepts vary quite a bit
we weren't just interested though in the
absolute number of concepts
we were interested in given that there's
this diversity
do people know when they use a word
that the person who is hearing it may
not be activating the same concept
that they are so to look at this uh
we collected a measure of conceptual
alignment across people
and the way we did that we did that was
we asked people questions like this
uh how many people out of 100 would
agree with you that x is an example of
concept y
uh we ask people to report how many
people they expected would share their
concept
and what we found was this
this plot represents people's
expectations for others to possess the
same concepts as them
if people were perfectly in tune with
the variants and others concepts you'd
expect to see all of the data clustered
along that diagonal line
but instead what you see is that people
tend to
uh overestimate how much other people
will agree with their particular
version of a concept in other words they
expect that when they use a particular
word
other people will share their concept
more often than is is actually true
so two people using the same word in the
same context
they do not necessarily mean the same
thing what's worse
they generally are not aware of this
fact it's easy to see how this
could uh be a potential hindrance to
effective communication
uh that was the last one so there you
have it that's four ways in which we
learn
uh these represent mechanisms we employ
uh to learn how to communicate as humans
uh but like i mentioned there they're a
lot more general than that
uh they're also employed uh to form all
kinds of mental representations and in
turn
uh they they form the foundations of
what we believe to be true
uh number one humans continuously track
statistics
two uh they seek out what isn't
understood uh
three they leverage statistically
reliable cues
uh and four they they continuously
update
uh even for things that you might think
not think of as being continuously
updated as
things like spoons that's all i want to
say
but i want to thank my lab especially
all of the people in pink there who
directly worked on the projects that i
spoke about today
uh thank you again so much for the to
the organizers and thank all of you
um for uh coming and listening to me i'm
happy to answer some questions if we
have some time
also if we don't have some time there's
my email
and my twitter and my everything so i'll
be right here
tell the pandemic ends in berkeley
in berkeley thank you very much
i think there is a question or at least
one in the chat
uh
manily
um we were production kids
i agree with you productivity certainly
does not
entail comprehension knowledge this
reminds me of a seminal at least speech
language pathology speech and language
uh oh this paper i don't know that paper
i will check that out
um yeah useful useful to know yeah it's
one of those things that people don't
like everybody kind of knows but we as
developmental psychologists
like how do you know what word a kid
knows uh there's lots of cases of
interesting anecdotes if you actually go
in and like
probe i was like what the kid knows when
they're using a particular word
i can't remember whose example this is
but their kid
used the word late in all of the right
contexts
they recognized it they they reacted
correctly when the parent used the word
late
uh but when you explicitly asked the kid
uh what does late mean they said
uh late is when you go to school and
everyone already has their boots off
um so that's like part of the definition
but that's like
a very limited piece um of what late
means and you'd never know that
uh most kids are not able to uh so
eloquently articulate
like their their definitions for work so
a lot of this just goes undiscovered
because we don't have great ways of
getting at that
and i think there was an earlier
question by marie as well in 1249
uh oh right um
regarding statistical learning am i
right to assume that the existing body
of literature
um uh
only accounted for statistical learning
exhibited in typically developing
infants
um uh no that's not the case so um
i mentioned uh uh there's more than one
person who has looked at statistical
learning in
um uh children with autism laura saskey
um has been interested in uh that topic
and didn't have a chance to collect a
full set
um of uh that population
uh before she she finished her phd
um but uh uh we've piloted that study as
we you don't need very much data before
you can get a sense of what the linking
function looks like
uh based on the pilot data uh uh kids
with autism didn't look any different
um from uh typically developing with the
caveat that like we before we publish it
we wanna we want a larger sample
older kids also yes appear to
have that u shape function that i talked
about
um other people who um have worked on
statistical learning in
special populations uh jenny saffron
actually has some work that was in
progress and i don't i don't know if
it's published yet but she was looking
specifically at
um statistical learning uh in uh kids
with
kids with autism
um am i missing sorry so many windows
oh yeah
um are you aware of similar studies
uh this is from paul best are you aware
of similar studies experimenting the
tendency to choose the second option in
adults
uh we have looked at response biases in
adults uh
and it's more common for adults to
actually exhibit the other bias
um so uh if uh you are tired adults
usually have a primacy
bias in those same kinds of questions um
uh
if you are tired um uh then that that is
likely
that is likely amplified if you don't
care um then that's amplified
uh why it flips may have to do
with adults being better able to
anticipate that like a choice is coming
up
so i don't care i just want to get it
over with um uh where kids probably are
not able to anticipate it until the end
of the sentence they're just kind of
lagged
so the choices have been named before
they realize that there's a choice that
they need to make
any more questions
then i would like to we're going to have
a few minutes of the closing but i want
to first express my
thanks to everybody and all the talks in
the workshop
it's been really incredibly stimulating
um fantastic and and also
guys
thanks for the last session to jonathan
into the list so i think david wants to
start a few
to say some summary words and michael
yeah sure michael do you want to start
yeah so um thanks everyone for uh
for joining i think it was a very
interesting
workshop at least i can speak for myself
i learned a lot
i think it was extremely diverse talks
from uh
biologists from computer scientists
covering uh really
an improbable mixture of topics that i
think otherwise
you wouldn't find basically people that
i think would
uh almost never meet together
at any other conference so i think uh
really uh thanks to the simon's
institute
uh for hosting such an interesting event
and uh i i think we heard a lot of
uh different things but also a lot of
common uh things uh well
to me i think uh the use of machine
learning uh
matters well i'm obviously biased but uh
seems like a very promising topic that
was mentioned continuously in the
research of different
species and not only mentioned but also
used
what we've seen today for example about
but research
we've seen i should be pronouncing it
properly i think that
it doesn't sound like bad videos and
also uh uh well obviously what we're
doing with the whales
i think the the the elephant sounds uh
are
look also very promising for uh for
using machine learning research then
some analogies that could be drawn from
human language
uh processing and uh developmental
uh studies in children uh uh
could be applied to uh non-human uh
non-human
uh species as well so uh
david actually had uh maybe a few ideas
about uh the follow-up
and uh maybe he wants to uh to kick off
maybe a short discussion about
what should be the next steps yeah
well thank you michael and thank you
shafi and thank all the panelists and
all the participants who stayed with us
for
for all these hours on on on screen um
i guess yeah this was this was really
really interesting
and my head is exploding and um and i
love the
interdisciplinary flair i guess i've
been in the last few weeks
you know thinking about the pandemic too
i've been reading some norbert weiner
and cybernetics and
and um really realizing how novel it is
to um
to really do core core disciplinary
interdisciplinary work is
is pretty on not not incredibly common
in in academia at least so um thinking
about next steps yeah we would just love
um
this is our our first foray um doing
this kind of
this kind of event and we would love
some feedback from from everyone on
on what they liked and what they didn't
like and what could be some next steps
and
are there other speakers or other
research areas that we missed
um and um yeah and
um you know and of course um you know
our our project uh
project seti.org we we want everyone to
sign up and
um so you can get updates and we could
we could keep in touch with you and
try to lure you into this um this this
tangled web we're creating
but um yeah just to open up the form to
everyone here on
on um you know on on their thoughts and
feedback of the
of the two days and
how i can get this plant in better shape
are talking to him her i'm not doing
well here
so i i guess my thought is probably the
thought of everyone and
and that's i would love to see some
translation between the work on vision
and the work on on
natural language or on you know
interpreting signals
obviously all of the stuff is signals
but the question is how do you interpret
seems like
for example first candidate would be
like the internal learning that mikhail
was talking in the context of nlp
and um in general there you know
speaking someone was a cryptographer
which is completely
the opposite right rather than trying to
understand you're trying to hide
but there are works in um you know
differential crypto analysis and
breaking
which are quite sophisticated but they
actually reminded me of some things that
mikhail was talking about
in terms of um you know what would be
the
the analogy to a patch and getting
examples from
from ciphertex and in general and other
things that sort of emerged here this
this issue of indistinguishability you
know trying to
uh characterize something that's natural
is distinguishable from random
um you're trying to generate things
by this again but in other settings
um i'm actually wondering whether this
approach of the unsupervised approach
from for language to language
translation
whether it could be applied for example
for translating fmri
data to images thinking of these as two
different languages
and applying a similar type of uh
mechanism
right now i'm using other ways of my own
encoders and decoders but i didn't think
of this
shared embedding space and so on as
it could be very well tools i could
borrow from
nlp so this is interesting
it is possible that that why the reason
why it works
for human languages is that language uh
basically this embedding captures not
only the structure of the language
per se but uh the structure of the way
that we express
uh we see our world and it probably it
uh
it is very similar no matter if you
speaking in french or in chinese
so it's it's probably something deeper
than just the language itself but uh
but but that's why i was asking about
how similar those languages are
because fmri brain activity and images
are completely different
and they're organized in different
locations it doesn't
like in language you still have the same
temporal order you said one sentence and
then another sentence and then a third
maybe the words in the sentence are
somewhat different in one language or
another but you won't
mix the sentences whereas in brain
regions
things would be organized totally
differently inside the brain than they
would be inside the image
so i'm not sure you know so sometimes
actually
are completely different so if you if
you look at turkish it has a reverse
uh uh order compared to english let's
say
uh sorry exactly reversed uh so um this
is a nightmare for interpreters for
example
but then
let's say you have an object inside the
image it has both
low-level features as well as semantic
features those things would be in
separate regions in the brain but
they're in the same region in the image
in that sense i meant whether they're
organized
uh you know spatially or in the image
spatially in the brain versus temporally
in different languages
the temporal order is maintained maybe
not locally but definitely at
above a certain scale it's maintained
across languages
whereas you know here i'm not sure now
so i'm just wondering
that's why i was asking about the
alignment of the embedding spaces and so
on
but image from racing knows do you see
so the simplest model
for language or at least that preceded
the deep learning is
is called currents uh so if
two words uh appear one after another
frequently
uh do you see something similar in fmri
so if you see two
visual objects in an image and you see
them separately will you get
some kind of a mixed response of each of
the individual responses or
something completely different i don't
know and
and i don't think these things are known
well enough in the brain i mean
people are trying to and i'm not a
neuroscientist so take everything
i say with a grain of salt but uh
not everything we see in the image do we
know where they are expressed inside the
brain okay it's not like i could tell
you here is the mapping from this to
that
whereas in languages you can't tell me
uh so
this is more like the rosetta stone but
you know with another language that
doesn't appear there and
you want to translate it now and you
have no idea you don't have any
knowledge
well neuroscience have more knowledge
about the language that you
but it's definitely not the same spatial
organization as it is in the image
and uh a lot is unknown
i guess another thing i found
interesting in the bat
research i don't think he's online
anymore but uh this
uh the compressibility is a measure
uh there was some point in the talk a
is whether the model is learning well
right and or
versus memorizing so i know that this is
a big question in machine learning in
general
um but it's also been used as a
definition in sort of a cryptographic
setting sort of um a
you know there's equivalences shown
between definitions based on
compressibility and definitions based on
prediction
a it's interesting to try to
show that they're equivalent to each
other and whether you can prove that not
just an empirical sense but in some sort
of a more
analytical theoretical sense
so it's also interesting i i also liked
very much what what jonathan was showing
towards the end and um about uh
trying to understand the language of uh
well aliens in this
in this case basically language that is
invented that is learned by the agents
i think nlp mostly focused on uh
existing language as well
for very uh practical consideration i
remember uh
once doing a testing and some unnamed
organization in israel where
the task was to uh to translate from uh
an invented language with a vocabulary
and a short explanation of the rules
and then you're given a couple of pages
and then you need to translate
so that was an interesting exercise and
uh i wonder if
even if you remove the rules if you just
are given uh
let's say if you applied modern
technology to rosetta stone
just one piece of it uh in one language
would it work would it produce something
that is
how about cryptography if you have a
you had let's say the enigma uh code
and you knew it came from a german
language but you don't know what the so
this would be like translating from one
language to the other
not having the one-to-one
correspondences but do knowing
which language this corresponds to
that's an interesting question
to apply that's an interesting question
to apply sort of modern methods
cryptographic uh
for breaking things that we know that
are breakable i would find it extremely
unlikely that it would break modern
things because then you would have
factoring algorithms that are based on
some
total you know you know
it would be i i don't believe it but to
break things like the enigma where um
it's an interesting question i don't
know that people have actually looked at
it
to i guess everyone here this idea of
compression
and how compressible thing is as a
measure of complexity
and uh distinguishing between different
species so you know we have these
elephants or even between
whales we have the sperm whales and i
guess you have some some hierarchy there
you suspect that some are more
sophisticated than others um
and then you have different recordings
and different dialects
is there some notion of complexity that
one suspects
that could be related to could be
measured
something seems totally unrelated to
like compression
so i i was um asking if there if there
are some notions on
um what what kind of language
the other species have so in in human
language we have some ideas about
what are the formal properties or what
kind of languages
say in the language hierarchy in the
chomsky language hierarchy we know that
human languages are mostly
context-free some some some in some
cases
some context-sensitive phenomena
and some phenomena are actually regular
or even subregular in realms of
morphology
um do we have any such idea
about human communication any way to
characterize it along these formal lines
i don't know i think uh probably a human
uh
non-human communication systems at least
from what i've read are
uh uh even not considered a language in
the pure sense
they like some of the features that that
human languages have so it's uh
it it's probably even difficult to start
what are what are the basic
units uh i think it's been a real
challenge
to uh other than the very simplest
sort of tests that a smear ecologist can
apply
uh to have a meaningful conversation
about that
so i mean when the meeting that i first
met michael and david
you know not so long ago there was a
linguist kevin ryan who may or may not
actually be
listening in still and i think the first
thing i said to david after that is that
i've never
had someone who calls himself a linguist
even
sort of interact with us on the level of
having those kinds of conversations
um so um and that gets into david's
point about why this is exciting from a
certain interdisciplinary perspective um
yeah i mean agreeing on on a universal
definition of complexity
across you know even primatologists and
male biologists has been a contentious
uh
debated thing for a long time um
let alone the shifting bar what might
constitute the sort of stepwise
uh progression towards what a language
is and what a communication system is
rather than just having these two
buckets
uh one that is you know uniquely human
and one that is
um so it's yeah i think that's one of
the reasons why this is exciting is to
get at those points
but i think there is compression-based
work to distinguish between different
writers
that their work sort of uh and between
different languages
so certainly couldn't so it's agnostic
to biology or species or anything it
just talks about
uh predictability you know compression
and prediction and it can distinguish
this way
which species we're talking about it
doesn't indicate necessarily complexity
but
it would be even for distinguishing
purposes would be interesting
so it's a tool that has nothing doesn't
know anything about the domain right
so kevin is here
now we have kevin so as well the
linguist of project setting well
i'm not sure that he's he's available
but maybe he
he can comment as probably the best
expert on
on anything related to language
yeah i think he may not be able to
because he's a
he's a participant rather than a
panelist so i think he can only use the
chat
or ask questions oh something that um
that kevin said in our workshop was was
really the importance of context
of that being important and i was
thinking of you know yossi in his talk
today um talked about the how he hand
annotated
that from the six bets um and then he
said he actually solved that but i did
he didn't he didn't show how he solved
it i was really curious to think about
that
on how we um you know we're thinking
about this these projects it's like
where do you focus on
um and i think the the work on um
you know on babies was also interesting
because we we sort of have an idea on
humans on
if we're trying to understand human
language at least we know ourselves
hopefully better than
than than than an elephant or a plant or
a whale
um but but to really understand where
which parts to look i mean i feel like
that's one of the
you know with the limited budget and
limited time you know which um
which aspects of the context are most
important to find
um are we you know we're for the whales
for instance we're focusing really on
audio
are we missing out by not including
video video is there
parts of the the context that we should
be focusing on more
um these are these are i think why
hearing from so many different
areas that uh helps us kind of figure
out where to
where to search as as we we put our
resources
into figuring out context
i think kevin is on now but you could
unmute yourself if you want to speak
oh hey i i have to go in a couple
minutes
but yeah i'm really interested
in these questions and i'm not so
interested
in whether x is language or not
because that's a fairly arbitrary
distinction and very human-centric
like human language has these properties
and this complexity
and we can ask how similar other species
are to humans
um but i'm more interested in
the question of just the one that you
raised
shafi how complex are these systems
and where where does that complexity
reside there's
all these different
modules of human language that were
discussed today things like
phonology morphology syntax semantics
and so forth and
we'll be investigating all of them and
seeing
where they fall in the chomsky hierarchy
and just more generally
yeah what how complex they are how much
information they can convey
[Music]
thanks kevin um
just the this discussion has uh reminded
me of
of something i i think i talked uh
yesterday about
um coup rumbles there's rumbles that
mothers give to their their infants
when they're comforting their calves and
an elephant once i i learned from an
elephant that she was about to
give birth or that her mother was about
to give birth
from listening to her reach to her
mother's vulva
and give this same call and i couldn't
figure out what was going on
and then noticed that there was this
mucus
um coming from the mother and she gave
birth later
later that day so i mean there are these
com
complex things that are happening that
elephants are communicating to one
another
um and that i just feel like we're just
scratching the surface
they're you know we see them doing all
these very complex things and then
there's
all this sound um so
somewhere in the future we're gonna
we're gonna figure it out but
we have a long way to go
with that with that promise
[Laughter]
i think maybe we should uh
you know uh say goodbye and we'll plan
for another event
and um again thanks everyone
it was really great one of my best two
days this summer
thank you so much bye everyone
thank you bye thank you